طيب انا حتى الان لم افهم يعني فسر لي
طالما كانت هذه الكيبلات مملوكه لشركات
الاتصالات كيف استطعت جوجل ان تسيطر على
المساله وتصبح لاعب رئيسي في هذه الصناعه
جوجل وغيرها من شركات البيجتك
اعتقد ان جزءا من المشكل يتعلق بشركه
الاتصالات داخل كل دوله فلقوتي الصراع
الحاد بينها وجد عمالقه التكنولوجيا منفذا
للدخول بينها جوجل وميتاج على صراع بين
شركات الاتصالات عبر لعبه شراء احدى
الشركات المحليه بهدف نفاذي لدولتها
[موسيقى]
ما دام انه من الممكن دفع رسوم لاستخدام
هذه الكبلات ما الذي يجعل شركات كبرى
تستثمر بمبالغ خياليه في هذه الكبلات
عندما تنظرين في اجمالي اي شركه تكنولوجيا
لانشاء خط ترين انه لا يمثل شيئا من
اجمالي ارباحها او اي موازنه لاطلاق مركز
معلومات مركز واحد للمعلومات يتكلف
مليارات الدولارات ولذلك فان امتلاك خط
ينقل البيانات لن يتطلب الا جزءا لا يرى
من كلفه المشروع كله لذلك يهم لهم هو
السيطره وكلما كانت هناك فرصه لهم لمزيد
احكام القبضه على الخطوط عريضه النطاق
فانهم لن يتوانوا عن انفاق المزيد من
الاموال
فكره السيطره والتحكم من المفترض ان تكون
تابعه للحكومات ما الذي يفسر تراجع
الحكومات عن الاستثمار في هذه الميادين
غالبيه ودول باعت قطاع الاتصالات
للمقاولين لانها رات فيه قابليه للربح
وبالتالي راينا الحكومات محكومه بمشاريع
ورؤى شركات الاتصالات التي لا تملكها من
اجل ضمان توفير الانترنت لمواطنيها
والانها نحن في وضع النرى فيه دوله واحده
هي التي تشرف على عمليه استخدام الانترنت
لان كل شركات التكنولوجيا تنتمي لهذه
الدوله ما جعل البعد السياسي اهم من مفهوم
المراقبه